ralph garman just waiting for my babble
brother to uh
hop on screen here had a little
technical difficulty
that's why we're running a little bit
late but he'll be here any second there
he is can you hear me
hello kevin
hey buddy we can see you
we can't hear you though can you hear us
hello
i i don't hear you at all you don't hear
me oh i
i hear you and see you
no nothing huh
please hold
we'll get this worked out i promise
we see you
can you hear me bud
you hear me for some reason you're
you're lying i'm gonna i'm gonna
disconnect and reinvite you
because we can't hear you
all right let's try this
is your mic on all right
let's bring him back let's try that
again
okay
well this isn't ideal
you there there he is
let me try that again
this is fun huh
is the way you wanted to spend a sunday
night
all right how's everybody doing tonight
uh we'll be answering your questions and
talk a little bit about the showbiz news
of the day
and uh doing what we normally do here on
the show as soon as we get this ironed
out
trust me it's a lot worse for me than it
is for you because you get to watch me
twist in the wind like a [ __ ] but we're
gonna fix this
he's gonna join us any minute now
oh i love you too tanya look at
everybody here um
let's see uh panda how are you ralph
hungover a little bit
yeah a little bit yesterday was a
cocktail party we had a good time
um notice me says someone whose name
isn't there so i've noticed you but i
don't know who you are
hey there zach good to see you
chris do we have the man
there he is the man the myth the legend
yes we can hear you oh my god finally
that was
so frustrating you have no idea oh i
have every idea
uh are you recording on your side we're
live right yes we are live
all right man well let's give them a a
real [ __ ] start because we gotta turn
it into a podcast later on
um yeah
yeah here we go it's time to babble the
[ __ ] on
it's hollywood babylon
with your hosts kevin smith and ralph
[Applause]
garvin
you've got crowd noise oh yeah i'm
loaded up oh
that makes me feel good it makes me feel
like there's a [ __ ] crowd here and
[ __ ] instead of
being alone in my room that was dope man
you
fooled me with your audio tricks um
wait [ __ ] let's do this the right way it
is sunday night
in hollywood so let's babble the [ __ ] on
man i'm kevin smith
i'm ralph garman hey uh
first before we dive into the fun holy
[ __ ] moments like that
i feel like i was trying before the show
began for those listening as opposed to
watching
uh desperately trying to get into
ralph's crowd cast
and uh through a series of [ __ ]
stupid errors and [ __ ]
i was in safari and not able to get into
chrome but i i got that was the problem
it was me
um but hey it all worked out and here we
are man
the adventure begins how are you sir i'm
well how are you holding up and uh
and yeah of our uh our lockdown
it's about to get much better i saw
somebody uh we're doing this uh
live streaming through ralph has a crowd
cast account that he uses for
the ralph report uh which you could
listen to all the time
uh weekly uh but uh so really sir
daily my bad sorry maybe do your own
[ __ ] ads uh in any event
um uh we're doing uh if you're
listening to the podcast version we're
doing this through uh crowdcast so
people
although we can't hear an audience we
could see them uh uh commenting the
whole time and somebody made an
excellent comment they said you know
because i was like oh i'm all
upset and intense uh they were like
smoke a joint kevin and i was like
that's why that's wizned advice i said
i wish i knew who wrote that but [ __ ]
yeah makes all things better sir
yes 456 people somebody just pointed out
here at the virtual hollywood improv
that's more
than we uh can put into the real
hollywood improv man seats tops 200. so
we're ready
and also that's just here in crowdcast
meanwhile
will wilkins uh net heads will if you
don't listen to the netheads give it a
listen
uh will is uh simulcasting this as we do
it live
on my youtube and on my facebook as well
so we got a bunch of people
uh watching us it's not just those in
the room there are a bunch of people
cucking it out from outside the room
right now so let's make sure we give
them a
a decent show hopefully you've gathered
some [ __ ] news to talk about
we've got a week's worth of stuff to
talk about for sure yeah um
nice before we get into that though
how are you holding up i know for both
you and myself it's not all that
different than our real lives because we
tend to work from home and spend a lot
of time
in uh hold up in our uh fortress of
solitude as it was but
are you starting to get a little chat
passed i'm getting a little cranky i'd
like to i'd like this to be over
no still no man like honestly there are
days i go
exercise every day by like taking a walk
and that's the only time i leave the
house it's i've
i've used my car so [ __ ] rarely um
but i'm
just using it to be productive like i
mean aside from today
was like this caps off my day which
began
with uh me doing like two other [ __ ]
live streams and stuff like that so i
got a lot of stuff done today but also
when i'm not streaming and trying to
like keep spirits up
i'm writing like a madman so i finished
as i talked about last time or maybe i
didn't i finished twilight of the mall
rats the sequel to
my write script and so while i was
waiting for feedback and stuff so i
could go and start doing notes
i dove back into uh moose jaws
for the first time in i guess four years
or something so i'm
currently doing a new draft of that so i
don't mind like
you know the world being closed i read
something today where our governor is
talking about
moving to stage two which is like slow
openings places with spaces restaurants
spaced out with new regulations and
stuff
and you know i'm happy for that i'm glad
we're going back to the real world
slowly but surely but
this hasn't bugged me one bit man i've
found it very productive for me
well uh i think everyone else has had a
little distraction and hopefully we can
provide that for them here tonight for a
little bit
uh we got some news to talk about then i
thought since we're on crowdcast maybe
if folks have questions we can pull some
people up on the screen
and they can ask their questions live if
we got some time can i have a second
bite at that apple it was such a [ __ ]
serious
answer i forgot that we were doing a
comedy show where i'm like i'm fine
don't worry about me working hard don't
cry for me argentina everything's fine
here um yes and
and i fully recognize it's different
elsewhere and stuff but
i have been surprised
uh by you know if you told me hey man
you're going into quarantine and stuff
i i think at the beginning i was like
i'm gonna have so much sex
we haven't had a [ __ ] ton of quarantine
sex and not for
like lack of of time that's for sure we
got nothing but [ __ ] time
um but i just i we had sex last night
for like the first time in a week and
i'm like
why aren't we doing that like every day
and she's like because you're [ __ ]
writing scripts and i was like
i'm gonna stop that i'm gonna stop that
coming here and never mind slipping into
a screenplay i'm gonna
slip into another human being um but i
realize that i'm talking about a sex
life
during the pandemic to a man who has
absolutely none am i correct
yeah thanks so much though it's uh it's
charming of you to bring that up
you know i've been i've been on lockdown
with uh carrie my
soon-to-be ex-wife and mother of my
child so the family unit is tight
but uh yeah socially i am i am
sequestered
i would imagine the scrotum is even
tighter at this point man you're looking
forward you're you're gonna be like a
sailor
like on on you know [ __ ] vj day like
when they let you
out man you're gonna be like wow kissing
nurses in the street and [ __ ] like that
they're gonna be like mr garmin wear a
mask
i'm just i'm just becoming very familiar
with myself these days that's all just
having my share of myself
i haven't even been jerking off that
much i mean i'm i'm doing the
masturbatory thing of writing [ __ ]
scripts that
entertain only me so i guess that's
close to jerking off but like
i haven't even been like pounding one
out on the on the daily man mostly i've
been
focusing on on controlling my appetite
and getting disciplined again i did a
i was trying to do a 72 hour fast last
week i wound up doing
that that's a 90 hour fast it's not it's
crazy i watched a video online and some
people like yeah i watch a video you're
a [ __ ] dick
you deserve what happens to you and i'm
like all right all right remember i did
have a heart attack a couple years ago
so i looked into i've been intermittent
fasting
ever since the heart attack and that's
how i lost weight and control the weight
it's uh i eat one meal a day and i've
been very candid about this
and i wait until a deep into the day as
it can get
and then uh at when then i eat and then
i don't eat for a while after that
so i i started looking up
more info about it and you know i
remember it sparked with uh jc who owns
the scum and villainy cantina
he had referenced it like a couple weeks
ago he was like i did a six day fast
once and i was like
that's [ __ ] possible and he's like
yeah it was great i felt fantastic
so i started looking into longer fast
because i was already on a kind of 18-6
hour meaning like i didn't eat for 18
hours and my feeding window as they call
it was six hours because i would eat
between
two and eight o'clock so now i wanted to
see like how what i could do with that
as they call feeding window and stuff um
and i was like let me see if i could
stretch it too i knew i could fast for
like a day easily and i knew in the past
i had fasted for like two days and not
by soul intention sometimes you just get
busy on a movie set and you forget to
eat and you're like oh crap i you know
whatever the day is done
and then i stopped eating at night so i
didn't put in any more
but like the 72-hour fast i watched this
fascinating video about what happens to
your body and all the positives because
naturally
like half the people on the internet was
like if you don't eat your body's gonna
eat your muscles and your muscles
[ __ ] eat first
and that's patently and [ __ ] true and
stuff like
joe rogan has had on a number of uh
doctors
particularly there's one really
entertaining guy that talks about
intermittent fasting it's not a diet
it's a lifestyle it's for you know when
historically evolutionarily speaking we
don't need to eat three meals a day
so i was like let me see if i could get
to the 72 hours because one of the
benefits was if you get to 72 hours
of intermittent fasting of just fasting
just water that's all i was taking
um stem cells get released and we never
get any stem cells action
at our age we're old men and [ __ ] so the
ability in any age to like [ __ ]
release stem cells like that's good
for a human body it'll probably go to
where it's needed the most and
in my case likely that's my heart so i
was like let me see if i can do it and
also a sense of
self-discipline it was coming after the
weekend of my
21st wedding anniversary with jennifer
so we were just pounding vegan ice cream
and
cake and [ __ ] so i was like this would
be a good cleansing and you're not
supposed to do it more than like once a
month
but when i finished the 72 hours it was
easy once you get past the 24 hours
hunger pangs go away and you're not like
oh i want to eat and [ __ ] you get mental
crispness and clarity it's [ __ ] nuts
man
proteins that in your body are weighed
and mired in sugars and stuff
suddenly become freed and kind of
rejuvenate like the health benefits are
[ __ ] staggering and stuff so at hour
72 when my fast was done
i could have eaten but it was eight
o'clock at night and i don't normally
eat past eight o'clock
but in this case i could have but i was
like well [ __ ]
if i just wait till the morning i can
tack on another
couple hours and [ __ ] because i'm going
to sleep anyway and stuff so
i went to sleep instead and then i wound
up like by the time i broke my fast
it was fully 90 hours man and like the
benefits i can't
i can't say enough about some people
tell me online they're like you're
irresponsible to talk about this i'm not
telling anybody to do it i'm just saying
that i've done it and i've only done it
because i've seen smart people do it and
talk about it and i'm like all right let
me see if i can do it and then it
becomes a matter of discipline if one
could pull it off so
i've spent some of my time doing that
and that's probably part of the reason
why i didn't want to [ __ ] that much
because jennifer
to me other than being like my good lady
wife and whatnot
two things i associate with her
obviously sex
and eating and watching tv
so i knew during my fast if i went near
jennifer
we would [ __ ] and then we would eat and
watch tv and my fast would be broken
so i stood i was kind of i mean i saw
her all the time we're in the same house
but
i was mostly down in my office so much
so that like when i finally broke my
fast i was like hey man i'm like sorry i
haven't seen you
that much in the last two days she goes
you just [ __ ] noticed
now and i was like wow i associate you
with food and she was like
that's [ __ ] sick and i'm like why
whatever
so i you know that was my story so much
for your mental clarity
yeah it all went away
well sir uh i saw that video that you
talked about and i watched it it was
fascinating when he was saying about the
growth hormones being released and all
that kind of other stuff and i've been
doing it
periodically myself but never for that
stretch so maybe you
yeah i mean you i remember like i came
back from the tour
and like i had put on some weight like
10 to 15 pounds that i didn't want or
anything like that
that came from not like you know like it
just came from
going from one meal a day which is what
i did at home to like
you know oh we're driving for five hours
well let's get something to eat and then
oh we're at the gig
uh let's get something neat it's all
vegan but like doesn't matter if you're
eating tons of vegan you're gonna gain
some weight and stuff and
sugar's vegan so i was eating things
with sugar and a lot of comfort eating
so by the time i got home
i was like 15 pounds heavier and when i
saw you
in person i was like [ __ ] i was like i
want to get
divorced because you looked amazing
that grief the grief took it right off
you and [ __ ] led so i was
and then i talked to you and you
mentioned intermittent fasting and i'm
like
[ __ ] i wasn't intermittent faster and
now i [ __ ] stopped and look how good
ralph looks and [ __ ]
so you were in the back of my mind when
i was heading back to it i was like i
gotta look as good as rough because you
do you look fantastic man and if it has
anything to do
with intermittent fasting then you could
back me up do you feel anything adverse
to skipping a day of eating no as you
mentioned it's more
in tune with how the human body has been
programmed over eons of evolution than
any other kind of eating because
you know the caveman would get up in the
morning and go on the hunt he wouldn't
have a hearty breakfast first he'd go
out there and just start working and
then
whatever he caught by the end of the day
he brought it back to his cave and
then he feasted so if that pattern is
much more
conducive to how the body is supposed to
work than any other way
man breakfast is a lot of hype there's
propaganda created by kellogg's and [ __ ]
where they're like you gotta have a
breakfast
you really really don't like you just
don't there'll there'll be a time where
you get a hunger pang probably around 8
or 8 30.
there's a name for it like it happens to
all human beings
but um you if you it's 10 minutes
late like 10 minutes later if you
preoccupy yourself you won't notice you
won't get another
hunger pairing for a bit again i'm not
saying everybody do this but if you're
interested because i saw a lot of people
uh after i posted pictures and talked
about it we're like hey man
tell me more um and i'd refer them of
course to people who really know their
[ __ ] but like from my experience for
ralph's experience
uh it's not the end of the world it's
fairly funny somebody wrote on the side
hollywood weight watchers so we'll stop
talking about it
we're a couple middle-aged men and we
found something that works for us
and it's about longevity [ __ ] we
would like to stay around
long so yeah man all right let's talk
about dead people now instead how about
that that'll just yeah people
people that didn't practice intermittent
fasting is what i'm guessing ralph
they're eating breakfast i'm guessing
it's time
for folks who left us way too soon but
left behind bodies of work that we'll
enjoy for many years to come
it's a segment we know here as tinsel
town stiffs
and now another
[Music]
yeah this was a tough one sam lloyd
brilliant character actor best known for
his work as ted
on scrubs has passed away at the age of
56 way too young
i saw that online i was not a big scrubs
watcher but i recognized him from other
things
you missed out you might want to go
revisit especially his work in that show
he was
so funny as uh ted buckland the lawyer
on that show
and um i always liked him in anything he
had a great resume i mean he was on
the west wing and modern family and in
the movie galaxy quest and a
ton of other that's what i knew him from
like galaxy quest if i remember craigly
i looked at his list
because i didn't watch scrubs um and not
because i'm like [ __ ] scrubs i just
never got around to watching it
uh but i when i saw them and then there
was an
outpouring huge outpouring of affection
uh on twitter and stuff and i was like
wait i know that face where do i know
him from and there were a bunch of
things i knew him from but just not
scrubs but
you're giving me uh your kick in the
pants maybe try scrubs how many seasons
they got
oh a ton uh
say eight maybe jesus all right i ain't
doing that that's way too much
what i'm watching right now and i keep
talking to anybody who'll listen is
shit's creek with eugene levy are you
watching that
what are you [ __ ] my wife on the side
is that why she's not
having sex with me she i just heard her
giggling earlier today and i was like
what are you laughing at and she's like
shit's creek
and we watched the first episode of
shit's creek like when it first popped
on
and you know i was like what do you
because i love [ __ ] uh
eugene levy and i love catherine o'hara
and you know after we were done i was
like what'd you think she's like it's
all right and then we never went back to
it because she didn't show much
enthusiasm
same way like i remember one day i was
watching like this third episode of the
american version of the office here in
my office
ironically in this room and i was
laughing and she came in she's like what
are you watching
i was like the american office and she
watched like 12 seconds and she was like
ugh
sucks and walked away i have never
finished watching the office there's a
bunch of seasons i missed and stuff my
wife
my kid would [ __ ] throw me out a car
to see one more new episode of the
office they became such
religious fans of it and i always
reminded my wife like
you [ __ ] mocked me for watching the
[ __ ] office and now you're still
[ __ ] watching and [ __ ]
same thing with shit's creek is
happening right now same way she was
just like
it's all right now she's just like oh my
god this [ __ ] show's amazing and i'm
like
i i i was there first
well she's right i mean it it it's not
great
it's good in the first season but then
it really finds its groove and
seasons two and three that i'm into now
are just
unbelievable i'm just saying you have to
watch season one to enjoy seasons two
and three
you gotta it's not a slog i mean it's
it's
enjoyable but it really starts to pay
off in season two and three and then
now i'm hooked i can't wait to finish it
the show built a
audience man a true following and stuff
like that like because they were on what
what channel were they it was like a
very little scene
they're on top but they came out of
canada on cbc initially i think
and then was it a canadian show that's
why they got away with shit's creek
probably
probably um i've been watching those
kids uh since i was a kid man
like eugene levy and katherine o'hara on
sctv
both a couple of geniuses man he's uh
he's working with his son which i
thought was so adorable and like how
awesome from that and that guy got
famous man
of course that show like dan levy's
become huge he is
brilliant on this thing and you're right
he co-created it with his dad
and some of his moments especially in
the late in the
you know the middle to later seasons are
just insanely great comic timing and
it's just a blast i think i'll give you
can i give you an inside baseball story
that's what we're here for babylon yeah
that's the case isn't it so
um at one point uh rhesus
canada not reese's america but reese's
peanut butter cups canada
was going to do a campaign um
and it came down to two
parties of candidates one was me and jay
and the other was eugene levy
and dan levy and having not watched
um uh seasons of uh shit's creek
like my hubris was like oh well
we'll get it because like us
yeah i mean like we've been around for a
while and stuff i mean i know eugene
levy but like
i mean does anybody know like who's dan
like this is we got this in the bag
we didn't get that job um is what i'm
getting at but i think it might have had
something to do with like i had a heart
attack and then i couldn't advertise for
candy
uh but i don't know if they wound up
doing it anybody in canada ever see a
reese's peanut butter cup
with dan and eugene levy man um it's so
funny though when i think back to be
like
we got that job in the bag we're more
famous than them and meanwhile shit's
creek has a
[ __ ] legion of fans so much so
that they finally touched your [ __ ]
poison black heart you never try
anything new
and and the other cold-hearted steel
woman in my life
jennifer both of you have finally
succumbed to the charms of [ __ ]
screaming
it did take a global pandemic to force
me
it was a perfect form also passed away
this week
co-screenwriter of the legendary horror
classic child's play
john laffia passed away at the age of
63.
he wait
the gentleman from scrubs what was his
death it wasn't covid related was it
no it was it was it's so sad it's hard
to even talk about he had 56
la end of last year weeks after the
birth of his first
child he was diagnosed with inoperable
brain cancer which
eventually spread to his lungs liver
spine
and jaw so oh my god
oh my god man like oh i mean it's not
even oh my god it's like where is god in
that like that's horrible
it was it's and at 56 right after the
birth of his first child it's just such
a horrible horrible story and
as you mentioned outpouring of love from
everybody's show but anybody who worked
with him just loved him he was a
talented musician as well was in several
bands and
you know zach braff and uh bill lawrence
the creator of scrubs just so many
people came forward to talk about beyond
his talent what an enormously kind
person he was
huge bucket of wind man
and as i mentioned john lafia the
co-screenwriter and creator of child's
play as well as the
writer and director of child's play 2 he
has passed away at the age of 63 years
old
uh don mancini who he co-wrote that film
with came out and gave a very nice
tribute to the man and
he contributed the line in the first
screenplay that most people remember
hi i'm chucky do you want to play that
was his and so um
he wrote that line yeah justin as we're
moving forward of course we've got a
bunch of people who are
sending us comments they said that he
was positive
uh what's his name the scrubs gentleman
oh uh hamloid he was posting positivity
positivity until the very end great guy
i'd heard that he was online still
like posting positivity and stuff um
that's i people like that are i
don't get it i can't even wrap my head
around it because i'm bitter and things
are good
so
[Laughter]
you're like i'm unafflicted and i would
never help how would i behave if things
were really hit the
hit the fan i have no idea so yeah um
all right so wait the second
gentleman the child's play guy yeah john
what'd he pass away from um mum
does not say here so not
but without ovid related no it's not the
best of my knowledge
um bummer man uh always
sucks to lose people in our business of
show indeed
is that it for the body cat is that
enough for you
grim reaper you're right i don't i don't
want that to be construed with uh
me looking for higher numbers i'm just
uh relieved yeah it's only
but it's only two uh wow
do you think uh one day um
one of us ralph will have to
choke through uh a hollywood babylon
you know uh tinseltown stiff update
where the
they we have to describe the other well
we'll have to eulogize the other guy
in tinseltown steps yes and would it
just be
like uh one section of tinseltown stiffs
are probably the whole episode more than
likely but
if we were to eulogize one another
um as a tinseltown stiff if you had to
eulogize
me because it goes without saying that
i'd be balling and [ __ ]
do you think you could get through it do
you think you could uh be a pro
like you got 200 people at the improv
mm-hmm uh and they're all
like [ __ ] you know they come yes i
died but they're all come for a [ __ ]
show and they're drinking so if you
don't make them laugh there might be
some [ __ ]
like you might get a heckler who's like
i know your buddy died i'm a [ __ ] man
up and make a jokey little puss or
whatever
[ __ ] so can you can you get through it
or do you break down emotionally is it
like listening to that beauty and the
beast song which reduces you to
[ __ ] puddle of tears uh
first of all if it's the first babylon
after you pass
i can probably book a bigger room than
the improv i'm thinking
a lot of people want to be at that show
so i can
i don't cash in on that show that's true
good point man go for a stadium if we're
ever allowed back in them
after this [ __ ] event and no i
wouldn't be able to just talk about you
and get through it that's insane that
would be
that would be ridiculous i would i would
i would probably not be able to get on
stage for a long time after that
uh i could i couldn't do babylon without
you so i don't even know what form that
would take but
if it was babylon i promise i would give
you a nice tight
four or five tribute and then i just
move on into
liam neeson [ __ ] jokes you better
believe it that i'd be out on the road
with [ __ ]
the babylon rest in peace ralph and
peace tour
behind you of me i put your jacket over
the back of the chair people go [ __ ]
nuts i'd walk out
i'd hold it up they'd be like guard me
go army i just put it over the back of
the chair and then for the next like
hour and hour and a half
i tell him ralph stories i'm like did
you guys know he was a [ __ ]
swinger
uh let me tell you about ralph garman
and then i do some of the departments
you know we definitely [ __ ] end with
liam neeson's [ __ ]
sure uh but uh yeah it's it's
like 30 minutes of tinseltown stiffs and
i'm just talking about you
i don't care who passes away that week
it could be
oprah winfrey or tom hanks they're not
getting touched because every
stop on the tour is a funeral for you
and i get to do the eulogy man
i'm making money off your death you
better believe it i didn't even think
about touring that's my that's a great
idea i should have done that
i mean a sinister person would take out
life insurance on you like in a [ __ ]
40s movie
but i'm just gonna tell you up front i
will ride your corpse for another few
bucks man that's for damn sure and i
suggest
i heartily suggest you do the same
just gotta kick back a little bit to my
kid probably you gotta let her wet her
beak a little but you know
merchandise because that's the sweetest
plum just a white
baseball cap with a with a pin spotlight
on it the center of the stage
there you've got it kid you've heard it
right here
uh each of us will make money off the
other end
and the other wouldn't happen any other
way i don't think i i want it that's
what i want for my boy what are we
otherwise what we put in all this time
for brevin six
same all right let's get to some other
news shall we in a segment we call
the hbo headlines
[Applause]
well done sir thank you well the movie
business has changed i hope you're ready
changed for some of us a long time ago
take for the director of yoga is there's
a real
[ __ ] changed picking on that movie
that's a great cast kevin smith film
greg you better be [ __ ] uh great
cast
just you know i just watched it fairly
recently because as previously mentioned
i'm doing
a new draft of moose jaws so i was like
let me get the scent back let me dive
back into my canadian weirdness and i
watched
tusk and yoga hosers and you are
fantastic in yogas as you like lit up my
night it was two in the morning
and once you came into the movie i was
like oh [ __ ] i forgot like we have
all of this now and stuff but as i was
watching that movie
i was like you know i get the hate
it's so it's so [ __ ] up
and it's so like not even just [ __ ] up
like tusk was [ __ ] up but this is a
real like
it dares the audience to like it and the
audience just responds like
how dare you sir no we refuse
this is too funny i did see someone on
twitter today that say they wanted to
spit on you because you made tusks so
you never there's no accounting for
taste and let me tell you something
nobody
none of the four people that ever saw
yoga hosers
have ever threatened me with like a
saliva salute
see classier group of people those those
yoga hosers fans
more selective that's for sure um
yeah okay the movie business has changed
for you that's granted but it's changed
for everyone else now too because
universe well welcome to my [ __ ]
world the rest of hollywood i'm you know
i'm used to being way out here waiting
for you i couldn't believe
this time i was out of that curve too
now nobody's gonna have their movies
played in theaters anymore
join me in tour world that's
that's where smart money is universal
announced that they made
a 100 million dollars with trolls world
tour directly
released to video on demand premium
video on demand as they're calling it
as they funneled it right into homes for
its opening 48 hours
and more importantly universal proudly
crowed to the
dismay of theater owners everywhere that
they got to keep an estimated eighty
percent of that revenue
as opposed to when it's released in
theaters and that the portion is not
quite as good for them so universal
i'm i'm no math genius but if you make
100 million and you
get to keep 80 percent they kept 80
million bucks
yes and the rest so
what do you think trolls cost to make
oh because mind you now that's that's a
good success i'm not taking it away
but they missed a plum that the sweet
plum the swedish plum
that they don't get to chase again um
now they'll never have theatrical ever
they spent
marketing for a theatrical and didn't
use it they pivoted so they're make
doing their best in a pandemic or
whatever but
that money they probably would have made
that money on home video
anyway you know what i'm saying that's
that's those are
kids movie numbers so i'm glad they've
done well but i don't think that
reinvents
the business this is a you know stopgap
effort
with something that they were like well
[ __ ] we've got no
income whatsoever but if we put this
into the marketplace
with skipping theatrical then at least
we'll have a little bit of income during
this time and stuff but
as much as that's a sexy number to be
like it made 100 million
like it was probably going to make 100
million
anyway the cost of a movie when you buy
it on itunes transactionally or whatever
is generally 20 bucks what were they
charging for this movie for this
debut uh for the opening weekend it was
20
rental for the for the film yeah the
only difference here being is it's a
rental price whereas like the rental
prices are generally
you know not as high as an ownership
price right but i just
i mean like i ain't taking anything away
i ain't [ __ ] on it like i'm glad
they made money and stuff but
if i'm the theaters i'm still not
threatened by this and i know that amc
and universal had a bit of a [ __ ]
pissing match this week over this
over the idea of like hey we're gonna
start releasing more movies digitally
like this this is the thing that
exhibitors have been terrified of and
fighting for
a decade or more at this point and stuff
the shrinking
home video window and you can't make up
like
you know if you may if let's say they
took the movie out and the movie made
200 million or whatever [ __ ] you can't
get that again
now that it's out on home video that's
like gone
and i'm also curious what the budget of
trolls was anybody write that down in
this article
because those animated movies are always
more than a hundred million dollars
yeah and this is a sequel and there's a
lot of pricey talent involved too you
got justin timberlake and anna kendrick
and
uh and others as well but i think what
really
teased off the the um theater owner
is universal's threat to do this
in conjunction with theatrical relief as
well
they're like well why don't we just
release it day and date
in premium video on demand and also in
theaters and just get
all the money that way and that's where
people took uh umbridge with them
and and theaters particularly will take
umbrage because they're like because if
you give everyone a choice between going
to see it in the theater and going to
watch it at home they're gonna irishman
that [ __ ] they're gonna go home and
[ __ ] watch it they're not gonna
ever step outside maybe for a marvel
movie but like that's it they're gonna
treat them like event films only they do
that already at this point they
[ __ ] don't go out unless it's a giant
event movie so
i don't know i don't i don't see this as
a
the end of the industry because i don't
see trolls as like well
that was the historic case that [ __ ]
broke the mold it making 100 million
dollars believe me i ain't taking
anything away that's
huge and [ __ ] but there's a big there's
a couple numbers missing from this
successful equation
one is what did trolls cost to make uh
and two
is what did the last trolls make
theatrically or worldwide that made them
want to make a second trolls because
that
made them go like trolls two was worth
it they weren't like oh we're making
this straight to dvd they could have
done that without justin timberlake and
stuff and anna kendrick
so trolls what did it make theatrically
then you look at that number and then
you realize all right split that in half
maybe or something like that that's what
they're walking away from
um and so that eighty percent
that there seem to be walking away with
on home video and stuff
is wonderful but there's still a lot of
money behind that in order for that
equation to work
the price of making trolls too has to
come down considerably and then you say
goodbye
to your talent as well because their
representation is going to want them to
get paid
that's my guess man but still good on
them it's awesome that they're like
you know they pivoted where they're like
look we got something on a shelf we know
kids are home
let's try it and they've hit a huge
number and stuff like that if it keeps
going
you know that's that's even better
instead i think it does remain to be
seen i mean that's an opening weekend
number that no one could have expected
ever on home video because of the
situation that we're in
but as it continues to rent and that's
the only place where you can see it
we'll have to see if it has legs as they
say in the business and see if it keeps
making that kind of money or whether
that was it they blew their nut on that
on that first weekend and that's it
mark hawke in your talkback said trolls
one did
350 million dollar box office so
lop that in half because that's what a
studio gets back
so 175 million bucks they made off that
movie that's what made them go like
let's do trolls too and stuff
right so you know it's regardless of
what it makes
almost half of that it's nuts
um i mean it's just it's not like this
equation won't work it's just the movies
will have to be
cheaper in order to keep doing something
like this um
but good for universal man i mean hey
number one
thanks to universal they gave us money
to make jane sound bob reboot and good
for them man they're making loot while
everybody else is kind of like what are
we gonna do
other studios don't have something to
put into the marketplace like that
but now universal is following suit with
uh the judd apatow um pete davidson
movie
the king of king of staten island i
believe it's called
yeah so they just announced that last
week and that was going to be a big
summer movie that was going to be like
you know this summer's big comedy they
were saying uh putting that into the
marketplace
you know they actually stand to make
more than they did with trolls
like opening weekend that's like
offering a brand new movie pete is in
the news still
like they're doing saturday night live
you know of
semi weekly at this point so it's not
like
he's lost people have lost interest or
if he's fallen off the map
everybody's home everybody wants to be
entertained they're looking to laugh and
[ __ ] like that judd apatow
an incredibly dependable brand like
i guarantee you that that that is gonna
break records
right there that's the one that might
change the industry because if they're
like
holy [ __ ] did you just see what happened
with the comedy because we can make
comedies really inexpensively
i think that's the one that might change
everything that's where the schism might
get wide
gotcha um that's mind you coming from a
man whose box office is
doesn't look like you know it's i
[ __ ] i don't know [ __ ] based on my
box office take it with a grain of salt
my opinion is as valid as yours
per screen averages though you're the
king we have some
we have some goofy records that we hold
but that does not
a box office analysis uh make me so
take it all the grandson uh television's
also
dying as well because fox just announced
their latest competition reality show
know if you saw this or not it's called
labor of love
it mixes the bachelorette with
knocking someone up basically and it
stars a 41 year old woman
who has everything according to fox a
career she's smart she's
but she doesn't have the one thing she
wants the most and that's to have a
child so she is going to meet 15 lucky
bachelors
and choose one of them to impregnate her
by the end of the show
and it is called labor of love coming to
fox
on may 21st so later well
we're we're already living the last days
ralph we're in babylon
clearly and everything is just falling
apart so why wouldn't you do a show
that's predicated on like
knock me up why don't they just call it
that what is it being called labor of
love
of love yes so will they be testing
these contestants sperm to make sure
that they can even
that they can even you know bother a
child are they going to check her eggs
out to see if she's okay that's a big
part of it and are they going to follow
them for a year
are we going to see she's picking a guy
or what's our update to come back with a
kid
ideally she's going to find a man that
she wants to start a family with and
they will stay
a couple but it never seems to work out
that way on these shows so i can't
imagine
that necessarily will be part of the
agreement and that's what bothers me
is that i don't care if the people in
the bachelor bachelorette are
ruin their lives it's entertaining to me
but when you're adding the third element
of bringing a child into the world and
then ruining their life too that's when
i start to have a problem
what network is this box of course fox
fox presents kid killers that's right
the show that's gonna haunt your
childhood and ruin your adulthood
they should have like the masked singer
combined with labor of love and just
never get knocked up by a guy in a mask
that she never knows
and she's like my dad was a zebra my mom
was a giant
phone when she's 21 they take the zebra
head off and you can see who your father
was
um man oh man that's uh you know could
you imagine
going back in time and and telling like
ed sullivan
you know what they do on tv one day
sperm
lots of it the plot of a show is whose
sperm
is going to be i like that a lot let's
do that i hate right here
on our really big shoe we're going to
have someone get knocked up
let's do it um i would call that a
really big shoot
yes of course um you answered somebody's
there's a guy i think his name is mike
hunt um hey that's funny when i say it
out loud um
that uh he was like ralph do an
impression
in a way that like you know somebody
getting dragged out of the bar because
they're getting mouthy about how chit
chatty we are like
hey do an impression funny man so you
doing ed sullivan kind of answers it but
they asked for your favorite impression
so i said
what would your favorite be um
i have two here mike my cud came back he
said
do a david hasselhoff impression there
it is
flap your fins seal i just do uh i do
drunk david hasselhoff i don't do david
hasselhoff
he didn't specify so give him drunk
david ass off at least you're answering
half his dream
you're giving him what he wants you're
like the monkey's paw
he wanted that you're going to give it
to him but it ain't exactly the david
hasselhoff he wants
no i drew hasselhoff from that video
where he's eating the burger
shirtless laying on the on the ground
when he's all drunk that's the hassle
i'm well aware of your classic ass off
i've been sitting next to you for every
one of these [ __ ] things but
he wants a taste give him a taste of
drunkelhoff if you want
this mess oh i'm okay i'm okay i'm
almost there
oh no this this is a mess
get me out of here let it never be said
i'm sorry michael you vomited on
yourself let it never be said
that this show doesn't deliver
exactly what you asked for right
um have you been following this
operation varsity blues thing at all
with the rich people who were
paying people off to get their kids into
colleges i think you were on tour when
it all kind of broke
i've been talking about a lot on the
ralph report and it's
it's my favorite fbi sting operation of
all time if there is
i'll tell you it made this whole story
made me go hug my kid and thank her for
not going to college
i was like oh i never even had to think
about this sort of stuff
i'm not even anywhere close to some
college cheating scandal or grades thing
because
there was no like we got to get her in
kevin by any means necessary or
something like that number one she was a
smart kid anyway
but so smart that she was like [ __ ]
dumb with school like after high school
and i was like
that's dad smart right there don't you
become no
[ __ ] sucker man that's just how they
get you
that's how they laugh
you want to educate yourself i'll take
you to the streets
the streets of highlands new jersey i
grew up in the suburbs
you screw up by the mean mini malls of
new jersey
i had to be home by five o'clock when
the whistle blew strictly
i was home yo exit 117.
in the house jersey shore
well the reason i bring it up is because
felicity huffman
of course wife of william h macy and
daughter of two girls
she was she famously went to prison for
a couple weeks anyway for getting
involved in this
racket where she was paying someone to
take her child's s.a.t
scores he was the doctor but he was paid
off to correct them and resubmit them
because she was concerned that her kid
would not be smart enough to
get into a college of her choice so the
funny part
is sophia i had wish i had parents
who gave a [ __ ] that much man like
my parents were like you whatsoever
yeah that's them basically there's no
you have no shot of legitimately earning
your way into college so
we're going to have to bail you out with
shameless money
or ralph and bear with me on this follow
me for a minute it's a way for a parent
to say
i love you here's all the help you can
get
that is that's not even helicopter
parenting that is snow plow
parenting yeah um we uh we helicoptered
in this house but we never
snowplowed and stuff and i was always
delighted when my kid didn't go to
school and she was like i'm gonna go out
there and [ __ ] work for it and [ __ ]
um you know i put her in a movie but i
put her in a movie regardless and [ __ ]
at the previously aforementioned yoga is
as well as inside bob reboot
but um she was less about like i'm gonna
go to school and
figure this out more like i figured it
out i need to go out and audition
and she felt she was running late that
that reminded me of me because i
remember when i saw slacker
i was 21 and i was like oh [ __ ] it's
like now
now i've decided to be a filmmaker i'm
so old like i could have been in college
doing this [ __ ]
so that's why one of the reasons i
didn't apply to like a four-year film
school because i would have been like 25
26
when i got out and that seemed ancient
to me so instantly i was like
vancouver film school man i got a quick
program eight months in and out and i'll
know how to make a movie [ __ ]
that's what i'm gonna do and stuff
because i felt like i was running late
and i've met
other people in life who have like tried
things and succeeded at things and stuff
like that that they wanted to do
and it seems to be a common consensus
where people are like no it's already
happening and i'm missing the [ __ ]
train and [ __ ] like that
that feeling of like i'm late when even
though you're not necessarily
um seems to be at the root of a lot of
ambition at least the people in this
business that i've seen
i have a funny impression to save this
because i'm just being serious now
fascinating stuff but i i thought it was
interesting that
sophia since her mother's incarceration
went back and retook the sats
and did so well that she was accepted
into carnegie mellon university in
pittsburgh pennsylvania all on her own
so
cmu i've been there i've been to that
campus man my ex-girlfriend kim lachrum
went there that's where i watched
citizen kane for the first time and [ __ ]
first time i went to a college like
breakfast bar like what the cafeteria
and [ __ ]
they have breakfast
they have breakfast all day long they
had a cereal bar you could have as much
cap'n crunch as you wanted i was like
i missed out on going to college i
didn't tell me this was part of it and
[ __ ] like that like i was going up there
to see my girlfriend at the time but i
was like
you go to classes i'm gonna be in the
caf and i would eat the [ __ ] out of that
food man
college kids got it so good with the
food but
back to you listening huffman now has to
look her kid in the face
and realize that she never thought she
had a chance to get into college then
the kid did it anyway so what was
all of that stuff she put her family
through what was that all for
and i think that's the great prison that
i made to live
her um
i mean it's a it's it's i'm sure
her daughter being what 17 because she's
in high school and this was pre-college
thing
yeah you know embarrassed
because she's involved in a nationwide
scandal
because of a decision her parents made
and stuff like that
but they seem like a like a tight family
i'm sure she's like forgiven her mom and
been like
you tried but like trust me man in the
world of
you know you owe me like i think right
now her pulling those grades and [ __ ] is
a real nice kind of like
you know i'm legit i didn't need that
help and stuff
she wins every argument at any
thanksgiving with the family from now
until time immoral here's the thing that
kills me is she wants to be an actress
it's like your mom's felicity huffman
your dad's william h macy you could have
done that
without taking the sats you could have
just been in
season eight of shameless or whatever
project they're working on i mean
there's
there's ways that you can get into the
business you don't have to go to
carnegie mellon
yeah but ralph you gotta understand how
unsavory it is to
practice nepotism in this business
felicity huffman
and bill macy you know serious actor and
actress and stuff that can't be
i would never cast my own kin i know
in something that's just like tacky and
wrong
and you're a better man for it may i say
um yeah it's true man they could like
you know you're
like you're already kind of in you know
some people
and sometimes they direct like you know
felicity huffman is directed
uh i think bill macey must have directed
some episodes of shameless but i'm sure
i'm sure i'm sure so yeah you're right
there could have been some access there
and stuff
i hope shit's cool with them man because
that would suck to like
you know they weren't like her and
felicity effort wasn't twisting a
mustache going like yeah yeah
these are just people trying to what
they feel do the is the best for their
kid and stuff and yeah
it's shakespearean how good a sense of
entitlement that pervasive sense of
yeah the entitlement that the rich and
famous had that i think rubs a lot of
people the wrong way because they don't
feel that the rules apply to them and
they can take these little
greasy side streets and nobody
really cares well it turns out people do
care i remember when uh
harley wanted to be in uh clinton's
movie and she auditioned
and you know the word was like he loved
her but it doesn't have anything for her
and stuff
and you know the kid was all ah because
she was like working on that part for
like months she wrote a monologue and
stuff like that
and uh i remember you know i was bummed
out for her but i was like that's
you know that's the business man we
don't always get what we want and [ __ ]
like that
and uh one day jennifer came into my
office and
sat down and she's like you know quentin
and i was like oh no i said no no way i
said look
number one i don't even know i'm that
good and stuff where i can call up and
ask a favor said number two
that is no lesson to pass on to our
[ __ ] kid like i would nobody's ever
called me
to be like hey my kid wants to be in
your movie and she's like yeah but you
don't make quentin tarantino movies i
was like that's fair point
and i never will i was like but i can't
do that as a slippery slope i said but
more than that more than the
embarrassment
of calling him up and asking for a favor
let's say i did that and let's say it
worked and then let's say she found out
then you got that situation right there
yeah the kids like you piece of [ __ ] you
didn't believe in me and stuff like that
like i remember when my kid was like i
want to be in once upon a time in
hollywood i was like
i even said to her i was like kiddo i
want to be in that movie you got to be
more realistic
like that you're not going to get in
that movie i i you know i i'm normally
the guy that's like you could do
anything you want but i was like look
even i have a sense of reality and
there's no way that you're going to get
into that flick
and i wasn't going to do anything to
like help her she did all her own work
and she
got in there and stuff but i was like
saying to jen if we helped and she found
out
that would be it we'd be done forever
you stripped her of her ability so you
might have a point ralph like maybe
her kid does feel like why did we go
through all that when i could have just
[ __ ] taken the s.a.t like didn't you
think i was good enough or something
like that maybe she took the psat
and took a [ __ ] though you know so we
don't know
maybe maybe college wasn't meant for her
i mean my god you just
the the things that people refer to
carnegie mellon is an acting school
though she's going to get a good
education as a
as an actor or actress if that's what
she's going there for unless she
and ralph i don't know if you know this
but hell of a breakfast bar
i've heard that cereal for days there at
cmu
if you've ever wanted to see the
carnegie mellon campus
um watch creep show
the the doctor with the crate when you
know how holbrick and the other guy
just tell him to call you billy that's
at carnegie mellon
it's all over the campus they shot that
movie because it was george romero
george romero of course was pittsburgh
based that's where he did
night of the living dead as well as dawn
of the dead
which was shot at the monroeville mall
which is the same mall featured in
zack and miri make a porno ralph i can
make anything about me
moreover zombies i remember that team
well
thank you uh here's my favorite story of
the week by far
you know a lot of uh people like us are
working from home now because of this
quarantine including a lot of local tv
news people
and then by the way might i just add i'm
liking it
so you know even this version of babylon
is pretty damn awesome like you know we
don't hear the collapse and the laughs
but
there's feedback on the right side i see
what's on people's minds and stuff like
that
so i i you know i'm i'm i'm kind of uh
i'm
you'll be hard-pressed to get me back in
that improv not because i'm a germaphobe
but more because i'm like why
this is easier i can wear my [ __ ]
bathrobe i'm smoking weed during the
show
that never happens ever ralph gets to
drink that whole show
me i gotta maintain the thc in my body
for 90 [ __ ] minutes or more
and this is just because when my drink
is empty there's no waiter or waitress
to come by to give me another one
now you sound like a felicity huffman
for your first
world problem where's the jeebs where's
my servant to fill my glass
i'm supposed to be making jokes for the
plebes
now i have to make another drink just
talk amongst the people i'm gonna make
my own drink i'll be back
uh hey kids are you enjoying this uh i
know you
are i'm watching your feedback and you
guys are adorable
yes i'm in a bathrobe this ain't a
jacket and it's a uh
a star wars uh knockoff of a
masters of the universe uh uh t-shirt
that i'm wearing that i got from uh
from the uh t republic i don't know
where do i get my t's from
anyway uh long story short if you're
enjoying this
uh you of course are members of the
ralph report garmi members if you will
uh if you're looking uh to another
spend more money on a [ __ ] show uh
that kevinsmithclub.com
is the place for you but never at the
expense
of uh the garmi never leave the garment
that i'll tell you i'm a member of that
kevin smith club
not worth leaving the garment for uh
please don't put that in ads
we're trying to we're trying to sell our
our enterprise obviously but
yeah we designed it this way like when
we opened up that kev smith club which
jordan had been working on for a while
right like the week the day two before i
called up ralph and i was like we're
doing this thing but i feel like
you should have the babylon library that
way like nobody
[ __ ] jumps from you to me and stuff
like that have you opened up the babylon
archives yet
not yet because again it was very kind
of you to make me that offer to take
ownership of the back catalog of
hollywood babylon episodes
but you did literally do it about a day
before you announced your thing so we're
we're now trying to get it um
figure out how it's going to live and
how people can get access to it so we
are
we're knee-deep along with the help of
as you mentioned before from ned heads
will wilkins is helping us out with it
and we're going to have a plan
of action soon and then i'll announce to
all the uh hollywood babylon fans
how they can listen to it hey uh [ __ ]
first world dean martin man now that
you've filled your glass
you don't have a [ __ ] waitress or a
waiter to help you are you ready to go
back to the [ __ ] comedy you got some
funny impressions or what i i am i am
ready thank you so much
all these people in my room
a lot of people working like we are from
home including tv anchors
week a tv anchor his name
alfonto merlos he was hosting estado di
alarma
which is a a live channel youtube
channel for a spanish news station
talking about of course the pandemic and
what's been going on but he's hosting
from his home
and in the background unbeknownst to him
was his nude girlfriend who took a uh
a walk through the bedroom in the
background while he was on the air
it's not the best part of the story
because a couple people have been caught
with their pants down
during all this turns out the girl
wasn't his longtime girlfriend it was
someone else that he was seeing
and the girlfriend found out from the
video of
him with the girl in the background so
he got busted for cheating on his
girlfriend
uh during the this sounds like the plot
ralph
of a telenovela um yes a lot of twists
and turns
wow you have done this to me i find out
that
that you're cheating on me yes the what
i get out of that story
you're a news reporter and you're on the
road make sure you do
your live feed from a toilet because
there ain't no room behind a toilet
nobody ever walks
behind a toilet your back's against the
wall you can see anybody coming into the
room and [ __ ] like that
so do your work do your business in the
toilet that's what my dad told me and
i've been doing it since i was a little
boy
also why are you in the bathroom for so
long kevin why are you in there
i'm doing a live feed with telemundo dad
[ __ ] off
there was another woman who was in her
bathroom at home showing how to cut your
own bangs because no one could get
haircuts
and she was in the bathroom and they
were shooting her and
in the mirror her husband was taking a
shower on the other side of the bathroom
but the reflection
in the mirror caught him buck naked
taking a shower so there's no there's no
safe place really
there isn't this house man well shower
with my
clothes on i bet you know i take the dog
out for a walk all the time shecky
chucky like rich uh reggie is uh
adoption low to the ground so you know
their carriage
not just their paws getting grimy but
their undercarriage can get grimy as
well
so it was decided in this quarantine
era that uh i should if i'm gonna take
shecky for a walk
that i should also uh bathe her when she
gets home because she gets up in
everybody's bed and she runs through the
house and
if it's out there on the ground she's
tracking around seemed like you know
fair enough
being cautious overly cautious but i
have never bathed
with shecky we have a very tight
relationship and i've never put her in
that awkward position of like
this is my dick you know as far as she
knows i don't have one of those
uh you know we just don't have that
relationship i'm the man and
even though i'm the man she doesn't know
if i have a dick or not
so when i go into the shower after the
walk
i go to bathe first i shower shecky and
then i put a towel out and i put her out
on the towel and then i get in and
finish the shower my own shower
but when i take her in i wear my clothes
so that i don't make her
uncomfortable so i wear my t-shirt and
my shorts
in the shower so that she could never be
on like some therapist couch
going like you know [ __ ] i lost
respect for him when i saw how little
his dick was or something like that and
[ __ ] so
i ten i do shower with my clothes on for
a little bit but for a good reason it's
not crazy
no no because you're concerned what your
dog might think that's your reason i
value that dog's opinion man
like she looks up to me she seems to
like me quite a bit and i like her taste
i'm a kevin smith fan so
me and her have a lot in common right
there um but yeah i give her careful
consideration
my wife is always like i wish you would
just say such nice things to me i wish
you would pet me
as much as you pet shecky and i'm like
don't you get it like you're gonna be
here forever man checky
she's here for like a minute like we've
already gone through three dogs they're
gone
they now live on the shelf to my [ __ ]
left man like in
boxes all their ashes and [ __ ] and
shecky's already 15 and [ __ ] so we got
to prioritize shecky's feelings
and you know she's made it this long in
life without ever having to be like
the man's got a dick what the [ __ ] so
i'm not gonna
vex her with that at this late stage in
the game that'd be like showing my dick
to my grandmother when she was 72.
it's just not right no no not at all
really it would be a very different set
of circumstances
another one being a person in all who is
capable of
much more cognitive thought
during the show isn't the best idea no
don't you take that away from me you
drunk son of a [ __ ]
now i'm living your life i'm in your
world now now i know what it's like to
imbibe during the show
and it's a lot better oh boy i have
pulled no punches now
you put me on a stage in front of a live
studio audience and i'm getting that
energy and though i keep smoking you
[ __ ] oh my god i'm gonna be higher than
a kite and i'm just gonna break into the
middle of show and be like ralph
finger is such a weird word right
because it's a thing that we have
like 10 of them and it's a thing you
could do but like you don't use that
where you say third base ralph not
finger right
how many shows would you make it before
you're like i [ __ ] quit you just
threw your papers in the air walked away
during that bit
that's when i that's when i walked
finger chunk is when i hit
all right let's let's get serious for a
minute because this is
soprano star joey pantaliano joey pants
was it i heard this i heard this this is
a serious accident this week
yeah he he got hit by a car and the
thing was
he didn't get hit by the car because the
car was driving erratically the car
was t-boned in an intersection and got
thrown
so far that that car was the thing that
hit him on the sidewalk when he was
walking
he hit a car that was like uh in the
middle of an accident almost at the tail
end of an accident
like it wasn't even and then the car
flew
and hit him on the sidewalk when he was
walking with his family he wasn't even
in a car
and you know not for nothing but joey
pants is not a young man anymore right
if i'm going to be 50 this year how old
is joey pants because he's been acting
since i was a kid
yeah he's he's well into his 60s for
sure
he was thrown out of the fence and got a
severe head injury as well as some
chest trauma as well but he's already
home on the men
he put pictures of his uh his stitches
up on
his social media and by all accounts
he's doing very well but got very lucky
he is an absolute american treasurer uh
for all the stuff we've seen him in and
stuff but i i actually got to work with
him for
a day on uh daredevil ben's daredevil
movie
oh honey mark steven johnson yeah i'm
i'm in a scene with
joey pants where i show him the billy
club and how it works and stuff like
that now i remember yeah
so it was very very cool and uh as
somebody who loved him in a bunch of
stuff i was geeking out with him
throughout the whole day
he is one of the best character actors
i know that the term that gets thrown
around quite a bit
but he's one of those people who makes
every movie he's in
better no matter how much he is doing he
can do one scene or he can be a co-star
and it's just
transformative he's a one-of-a-kind
talent i love him in everything
the matrix is uh telling me this is
steak
remember that scene oh yes right
um i thought you were stoned for a
minute and you were just going off on
something
it's like the matrix is telling me this
is steak
ralph's like i gotta finish this show
midnight run
alone for that performance at midnight
ron just uh
he's the guy that says the title and
it's a midnight run for christ's sakes
without him they got no title
all right remember he's the one remember
he's in uh in the sopranos
he's the mob guy who likes to have sex
with the [ __ ] gun
and he likes to like to bottom from the
top like it's implied that he takes it
from janus
yeah sister ralph stefaretto
yeah yeah i'm sorry i just went [ __ ]
all chris farland like remember that
that was awesome i have no follow-up
yeah uh the ruth brothers
are back in the promise of putting
heroes up on the screen
but they're not well not marvel heroes
but they are disney heroes they're doing
uh the hercules live action film based
on the animated film from the disney
vaults
they will be producing although they
will not be writing or directing but
they will be guiding the uh the hand of
both of those other talents and um
what do you think hercules the
live-action movie i mean disney is
leaving no stern on
stone unturned when it comes to taking
their animated catalogue and turning
them into live-action films
i don't know if there's an audience for
this one or not what's it
what makes it the cartoon hercules and
not just you know hercules
the music i assume so they are going to
keep the music
i'm sure they will they've done it in
all the other animated musicals that
they've turned into live action
i remember they had the uh vanities or
the the girls on the
the grecian urn like the greek chorus um
but do you remember a single song from
hercules was there a track
i don't remember i liked hercules but i
haven't i've i remember when i saw it i
enjoyed the [ __ ] out of it liked it i
have not seen it
since so i don't i when this when i
heard this i was like
really are you sure they're remaking the
cartoon version because you could just
do a hercules like there was nothing
that i remember all that specific about
that particular
version but this is how they do they
just go back into your childhood they're
like what'd they like
do it what'd they like do it every time
i think i liked something from the
animated hercules musical
it turns out to actually be from the
emperor's new groove
i keep flashing on moments i'm like oh
that was a good sign oh no
that was that was the other one that was
the other one so i don't remember
anything from hercules and i saw it
i do that all the time but that's just
because of the weed
i'm always like yeah that's gotta be the
cars nope
that was from the emperor's new crew
right that's got to be
[ __ ] some scandinavian death metal
nope no that's from the emperor's new
groove
yeah hey it's time for geek news
[Music]
speaking of disney disney is uh
making character face masks now for the
kovid 19
generation if you want to go out are
they are they given the proceeds to
charity
they are donating one million dollars of
the proceeds to a charity called
medshare which is an
atlanta-based non-profit that delivers
medical supplies and equipment to places
around the world so
one million dollars of whatever they
make will be
sent to that charity and they're also
donating a million of the actual masks
themselves to the charity as well
so they're doing it for the right
reasons but good on them good on disney
um i i was having my gun make mess she
made this
really great mask set a mask for us and
i was like oh my god and they're made
out of like superhero
shirts and [ __ ] like that um so i was
like can you
make like 50 of those man we'll make
them and [ __ ] sell them at the store
and then i was like we can't sell them
at the store i don't want to profit off
this
so i figured like when the store opens
when everybody comes in like here have a
[ __ ] mask we'll do them as giveaways
and out here
if we do hollywood babylon we can do
them as giveaways and stuff like that if
we're
allowed to go there's four stages we're
in stage one
stage two is restaurants stage three
it was like gyms and [ __ ] stage four
is us performing artists so it's going
to be a while before they
let us get back to doing what we do in a
room but as we've discovered
[ __ ] the room man we got crowd cast we
got this
uh all the characters going to be
available star wars marvel pixar
disney you name it you'll be able to put
a disney mask on your face
it's only uh 20 bucks for four and
they're
scented they're set to ship in june
which made my heart cry when i read that
because
everyone's still believing that in june
we're going to need these masks but
they're probably true so legion m the
good folks who uh
were involved with this on jay and salam
bob reboot wonderful organization
fan run organization fan owned
organization
they are uh doing jay and silent bob
buddy christ masks i believe they're
giving all their
profits to charity as well or something
like that so
yeah this is you should do a series of
of kevin smith film match you should
have a dogma mask and a tusk mask
and uh and a yoga hoser's mask
um how soon before you see the mask with
a dick
like in a fake mouth or the [ __ ] mask
or something like that with decals like
that before people are like
hey man you can't wear that mask in
there you know that
mask is obscene look his mask is saving
my life man
see what it is man back off six feet
i can't wait to get back to a world that
trivial if we ever do
yeah i'm with you buddy that's it for
today's show
topic wise we're all done that's it
the tank is empty well we went like an
hour and 15 and [ __ ] yeah we did all
right i mean
pretty damn sweet for a sunday night and
stuff a lot of people back east are like
[ __ ] it it's time to go to bed anyway
man
um yeah what is it i said yeah they're
like yeah enough with you two they're
reading their watch saying i want to go
to bed
show's falling apart where i'm like
repeat yourself what i can't
[Laughter]
talking about um oh my god man uh
ladies and gentlemen of uh the internet
of uh the crowd cast have you had a good
time this evening i'll wait for them to
type
[Applause]
uh boy oh boy man uh we uh had a great
time doing this uh but
let's be honest folks there's literally
no show no hollywood babylon ever
without the man in this box over there
uh here's the story of a man named
carmen ralph
[ __ ] garmin give it up for him
ladies and gentlemen
let's hear from my good pal and babble
brother mr kevin smith
and that is hollywood babylon for this
week i'm kevin smith
i'm ralph garman babble the [ __ ] off
good night hollywood and the rest of the
world
wash your hands
[Music]
you